we are learning more about this meeting
that Donald Trump jr. had with the
Russian lawyer Natalia vessel mitts kaya
in Trump Tower last June of 2016 this
was the first definitive proof of
Russian interference in the election we
have written evidence now Donald Trump
jr. has been painting it as a total
waste of time
with nothing of value coming from it
that was such a waste of time that he
didn't even bother telling Donald Trump
senior about it
we have now learned that there were even
more people in the meeting than
originally reported we knew about the
lawyer herself right Netanya Natalia
vessel Mnet's kaya and of course Donald
Trump jr. was there Jared Kushner was
there and Paul Manafort was there that
was four people we've now learned and
this is just stunning that a Russian
American lobbyist named Renaud Ahmed
chin was also in the meeting and he is
known for opposition research exactly
what the meeting and Trump Tower
purported to be about if you wanted to
collude with Russia to smear a political
opponent Renato
Ahmed chin is sort of like the first
person you'd meet with because this is
his area of expertise and he was not the
only other person in the room he gets us
to five people in the room but we've
confirmed the presence of Rob Goldstone
the publicist who arranged the meeting
to begin with that gets us to six people
in the room we've learned that a
translator a Russian translator was in
the room that gets us to seven as well
as a representative of the Russian
family who asked for the meeting to set
up that gets us to eight people minimum
this is a lot of people in the room pad
for a 20-minute waste of time that was
so not memorable that Trump jr. Kushner
and Paul Manafort all initially forgot
to disclose it quite a team of people in
there for something that made no
difference and remember how Donald Trump
juniors story it changed four or five
times when more information came out
from the New York Times well after all
of that Trump jr. went on sean hannity
show it should have been a safe space
for him door and he said that was it
that we weren't going to learn any more
about this meeting turns out in the next
24 hours we find there's more people in
that room yeah but I'm sure now we have
the full story right because even though
there were like four or five instances
where the truth wasn't told about this
meeting now they're no longer telling
any lies and they're being fully upfront
about everything that happened it's
almost like his credibility has been
destroyed on this day I know that what
we're noticing is he's willing to be
super upfront about whatever details
have or are about to be leaked by the
New York Times or Washington Post he
gets super honest and transparent as
soon as he learns that's going to happen
uh this is gone
beyond the shock and surprise at the
depth of the intent to collude this is
now under the umbrella of major national
security concern we have an
administration that could be completely
compromised to Russia and more sensitive
to the desires of a foreign power than
they are to the actual needs of the
American people